here's another little beef story we have
more beef actually
yeah we do have more beef
i do quickly want to update everyone on
the homestead situation oh okay okay was
that in the bonus we talked about in the
main uh we talked about that in the main
little update so you know i'm not don't
you don't have to go brigading their
comments that's not what i was looking
for but some people took it upon
themselves and the comments were really
funny the irony of the whole thing was i
was really irony but they posted a
picture of the place i stayed at
after yeah the episode came out yeah
like to stick it to you no i think they
had no clue
no way dude it was the same [ __ ]
person that sent me the balenciaga had
maybe yeah contracts for both companies
yeah it's just one intern yeah yeah well
you're gonna get fired [ __ ] you you know
if you go to their other posts
their engagement is asked yeah like one
comment like one bot comment it's like
oh beautiful or someone being like i'm
all alone and [ __ ] wet so the post
someone sends it to me and they're like
damn they're already getting them
i was like oh that's a little nervous i
don't know what you guys are going to do
it's 44 comments all of them just that's
dope when did the ceo come on the bed
sick does this house come with [ __ ]
stains wow your your ceo must come it
was just like all ceo come come
when a few posts back so they limited
comments on everything and they deleted
that post like some [ __ ] have they
not reached out to you directly still no
what no yeah
what no that's absurd yeah i'm surprised
they didn't the caption wasn't like our
beautiful remote place with a very
joshua tree that is not spooky at all
yeah
and it's a very clean bed and very clean
and our ceo dark gray not black
which have asphalt gray
sheets okay and dark obsidian is the
color of the comforter and barely any
[ __ ] and the only place to come is here
okay so many people were like hashtag
refund noel i was like i kind of like
this
it's kind of like i went to jail or
something it's like free me like
i would go to the page and look at those
right now but on my ipad here yeah but i
[ __ ] blocked them so i can't look at
[ __ ]
that's that was their tone with me when
i was like talking to him about sorry
i'm just blocking him again i was on the
pad
what's up you just unblocking him to
block him again yeah yeah just to stick
it to him that was their tone with me
obviously when they were going back and
forth with me we didn't go back and
forth i wasn't even i wasn't even a dick
or anything i was just cool i'm like and
i went back and read what i said and i
was like dude i was doing more to figure
it out than they were i was like oh do
you maybe have another place open nearby
like i'm willing to that and they're
just like no
everything's booked it's a nice house
it's not scary it's october you [ __ ]
you're supposed to be a little spooked
out all right it's [ __ ] october it's
in the theme you clearly haven't been to
a haunted house yet this month we know
yeah so just get spooked out a little
bit okay is there any other house i
could how about this sack the [ __ ] up
dude is there any other house i could go
to they just sent me a screenshot of
security camera in the house just
watching us like a secret one how are
you doing that sack the [ __ ] up you
think this is scary yeah you haven't
seen anything yet yeah it'd be funny if
they sent you a picture of like a bounce
house or something like that and they're
like here you go here's a house for you
a little yeah
[ __ ] little [ __ ] they get that [ __ ]
from kindergarten that big like rainbow
parachute that everyone would run under
they're like oh maybe this would be a
better home for you
you [ __ ] weenie i would have almost
preferred a nine paragraph subtweet we
could keep this going yeah but the fact
that they're just convinced that you
know like some like anal like realtor
was like no this is a beautiful home
it's like it's not yeah it stinks
it [ __ ] sucks and everyone that likes
that house
probably
does sex trafficking i don't know
[Laughter]
and you can quote him on that yeah yeah
yeah put that in the [ __ ] new york
times oh no i'm gonna start like a whole
other like conspiracy like remember when
wayfair everyone's like the 40 000 hat
they're hiding kids they're gonna do the
same [ __ ] with homestead on the tmg
podcast noelle said this house came with
[ __ ] stains so now we have homestead beef
right we have balenciaga beef and uh i
don't really see an end in sight for
either of those no but now we have
celebrity beef as well do we want to do
this machine gun kelly hit me up no no
no i'm kidding but could you imagine
it's not that it's uh oh yeah do we want
to i feel like actually yeah i think
it's fine i think it's fine so we
noticed that garyvee follows us on
instagram yeah right and and so you know
we've dm'd a little bit now but we're
not i tried but he left me on red you
want the smoke that's all right i
understand well i mean like it's better
than what he sent me yeah he's sending
me his own stuff where he talks about
like
people that hate on other people oh yeah
you hate her and he's just like send me
that and then i'll just like it and i'm
not really sure what the relationship is
at this point he's cooking you does he
hate us
does he like us i have no idea i don't
know
we have to find out that's a wild thing
to do send dm someone a clip of yourself
saying something to someone else that's
vaguely related to like
the it's just crazy yeah real homestead
moves right there it is yeah it's kind
of a
boss ass move honestly yeah i'm not even
gonna write anything i'm gonna send you
a clip that i already recorded because
that's how little i care about this
conversation i already spoke about i
already said some [ __ ] i'm not even
gonna waste my time writing new words
you should have responded by
like
like downloading the tick tock of us
talking about him and then just sending
him the raw file so it's like play video
and he
opens it
and it's just us you like dogecoin right
picture your family eating 5 000 marbles
picture yourself microwaving vomit and
then eating the vomit
you like racing right yeah
picture going into the urinal at four
o'clock
and eating the [ __ ]
produced from all the adrenaline
of all drivers on track that day dude so
many people and the bonus said that we
actually made them almost pee
[Laughter]
and the thing is with the people
listening right now you don't even know
what we're talking about yeah but we had
like we had like a gross out challenge
at the end of the last bonus episode
where we like
tried to make the audience
vomit imagine popping a pimple directly
into your mouth
imagine witnessing a bowl of italian
gnocchi
and you bite into the first one and you
realize they're all cysts
someone is sitting at their desk right
now i just went
[Laughter]
so you want to know about shiba inu coin
huh
imagine a bucket of hot diarrhea
sitting in the sun
yeah this is the one he sent me i watch
this play it
wanna do or you might be thinking is
interesting because
you
say no you say no that's stupid that's
stupid while you're saying that's stupid
or she's stupid or they don't get it or
that's ridiculous or shit's [ __ ] up
people are out here [ __ ] executing
[ __ ]
talking [ __ ] from the sidelines eating a
[ __ ] hot dog and drinking a slurpee
has nothing to do with the athletes on
the field
remember that the sports analogy there i
thought he was talking about this
that we had yeah i was gonna say there's
a lot of people on tick tock who
disagree with that yeah what's that man
don't [ __ ] on the slushie cup yeah yeah
sitting on the sidelines
i mean does this count we're in space
no we're
much more sidelined than us you can't
get much more condescending than space
we're literally looking down on everyone
it's true okay that's true yeah yeah
this is this is the dm he said had to do
it which i don't know also don't know
what that means like had to send this to
you or i had to say it because you suck
i don't think he i don't know if he i
don't think he actually dislikes us i
like him
yeah i like him i just
i think he's really easy to make fun of
but obviously he knows that he seemed
like he he always comments on people
that like roast him yeah and the dude
who does the impersonation of him yeah
he said it was really funny yeah so
i don't i don't think he takes any of it
personally well
i i think right now it might be a little
bit of a beef and i don't know it's kind
of like a skirt steak
a little beef
you